Buenas tardes Raúl me encuentro aquí en
la Plaza de la república donde dentro de
una hora debe comenzar Esa marcha que
nos llevará hacia la Plaza de la nación
no muy lejos de aquí hay que decir que
por ahora el ambiente es tranquilo hay
mucha mucha gente de hecho todas las
calles que traen hasta esta Plaza están
cortadas y vigiladas cercadas por la
policía que quiere evitar que lleguen
hasta el centro de París personas
encapuchadas que van a generar destrozos
con respecto a la huelga está haciendo
bien aceptada está haciendo una adhesión
muy alta sobre todo en las regiones más
que en el año 2019 recordemos que este
proyecto de Manuel macron que en la
época se llamaba el proyecto de la
Reforma por puntos también ya había
suscitado un movimiento social eso se
vio interrumpido por la pandemia del
Coby 19 por lo tanto Hoy está haciendo
una adhesión a semejante sobre todo los
transportes en el metro sobre todo Raúl
ellos lo habían prometido decían que
querían paralizar el país un poco menos
en los ferrocarriles y también muy de la
educación secundaria dice los sindicatos
un 65% el gobierno dice un 30% Hace
algunos minutos habló el líder de la
cgt1 de los sindicatos más importantes
del más a la izquierda obviamente como
decías tú ya son diez los sindicatos que
aprueban este movimiento hace muchos
años Que en Francia no se veía algo así
pues normalmente la cfdt que es el
sindicato más conservador se aliaba del
gobierno pues está bien también está con
la marcha dice que va a ser más personas
que en el 2019 cuando se reunieron más
de un millón de personas en las calles
de París y de Francia 250 movilizaciones
en todo el país hablemos Erika de estas
exigencias de los manifestantes que
están en las calles
como tú lo decías muy bien a Raúl la
mayor cosa que preocupa a los sindicatos
y a los trabajadores en general ese
aumento de la edad jubilación de los
sesenta y dos a los 64 años la gente no
quiere trabajar más también ese aumento
de la edad de cotización a 43 años en el
2027 Hay que decir que ese aumento se
iba a producir pero en el año
2035 según un último proyecto que hubo
durante el gobierno de françois olondo
la gente en general considera que este
proyecto de reforma va a perjudicar a
los más pobres aquellos que tienen las
carreras más duras más difíciles que no
van a tener ganas de trabajar después de
los 64 años de edad que sufren muchos de
problemas de salud ligados obviamente a
sus trabajos difíciles y también dicen
que en general es un proyecto desigual y
que ha contado además con la complicidad
por decirlo de alguna manera de la
derecha el gobierno ha atado todos los
pedidos las solicitudes que hicieron los
miembros del partido de los republicanos
para que se integra este proyecto la
edad de jubilación o también fijar una
pensión mínima y por lo mismo el
gobierno piensa que lo va a aprobar sin
utilizar ese cuarenta y nueve tres ese
artículo que permite aprobar los
proyectos de ley sin votarlos en la
asamblea nacional pues va a contar con
la mayoría que no tiene después de las
últimas elecciones legislativas gracias
al partido de los republicanos pero hay
que decir que un 66% de los franceses
según una última encuesta está en contra
de este proyecto incluso dentro del
partido de los republicanos de derecha y
muchas voces en contra de este texto del
gobierno de Manuel macron y Elizabeth
Erika como siempre Muchísimas gracias
por toda la información desde París por
supuesto muy pendientes a lo que va a
ocurrir durante toda esta jornada de
movilización es masivas cerca de un
millón de personas o más en las calles
de Francia en rechazo a esta propuesta
pensional de presidente Manu